South Korean president moon jaein said
that he was going to deliver a secret
message from Kim jong-un the North
Korean leader to president Trump what
was that in that message so the message
is that we've been receiving from
Chairman Kim have been very consistent
they are that he is intent on
denuclearizing he understands that he
understands the scope of that and what
that means
he's been very consistent in his
commitment to delivering on that promise
we need to find our way forward to
achieve that for the world it's it's
great I'm here at the UN this week
these are UN Security Council
resolutions that are being enforced but
it's a lot of words at this point and I
know you have been clear you have set
key demands I mean has the North
declared their stockpile yet no right I
mean have they set a timetable to give
up these weapons no have they agreed to
inspectors what steps have they taken to
show proof that they are going to
denuclearize no I've been pretty
consistent I've also been consistent
about the other item which is I'm not
going to talk about the conversations
the negotiations each day the twists and
turns what we're going to do is we're
going to continue the good work we have
we're going to make sure there's no more
missile tests no more nuclear tests
we're going to continue to work on
getting American remains back we're
going to continue to work towards
denuclearization and it will take a
while there will be a process to this
president Trump's been clear about that
and clear-eyed about that since the very
beginning